[Music]
malice
you know what i'm talking about that
gooey reddish purplish
evil substance that coats many parts of
the land of hyrule
and is shown to be spewing infinitely
out of the corpse of ganondorf
forget everything you know about it at
least just for this video
because what i'm about to talk to you
about goes against all of the other
popular theories on what malice is
such as the theory that it's always been
a monster life force of sorts that
manifests as a purple colored cloud when
an enemy creature dies
or the theory that it is the very same
substance as the evil crystals from
skyward sword
this theory that i'm going to talk to
you about is so different
and so crazy that it just might
work it's also kind of nasty in that ew
grows kind of way so you know
forewarning here
let's get right into it malice is all
over the place in breath of the wild
it's in the overworld in sheikah
technologies and even in the depths and
heart of hyrule castle itself
in fact every form of ganon we encounter
in the game is completely made of this
malice substance in the breath of the
wild 2 trailer
we can see where we assume malice
originated from
ganondorf in the trailer we see him as
this mummified dude that's just sitting
there
spewing a bunch of thick tendril-like
malice out of his body
well have you ever wondered how exactly
this rather
dry looking mummified body of ganondorf
is just spewing a limitless amount of
malice out of it
the immediate thought here is that this
is happening as a result of the original
curse of the demon tribe
introduced to us by demise who stated
that an incarnation of his hatred would
forever follow those who carried the
blood of the goddess and the spirit of
the hero
that's pretty easy to understand but
it's when we try to connect
that ancient curse with this actual
tangible
eyeball-filled goop found all over
breath of the wild that the theories
start happening
it's because this is the first time
we've ever seen malice also known as
evil represented tangibly like this and
in this quantity
and it's also the first time we've ever
seen ganondorf wielding or producing
any kind of power that doesn't stem from
either his own wizard abilities or the
triforce of power
much less while being you know dead the
question
i'd like to ask here is this even if
demise's malicious intent has existed in
some way for the entirety of the zelda
franchise which i'm not questioning
what happened to make it manifest
specifically
this way in breath of the wild what made
malice breath of the wild has long been
speculated as being heavily inspired by
the works of studio ghibli
particularly the movie called princess
mononoke i mean fans of the film will
pretty clearly see the visual
resemblances between link and the film's
protagonist ashitaka they're both
youthful boys who dress in tunics and
hoodies wielding bows and arrows and
swords riding through very green fields
on the backs of their trusty steeds they
also both have hearts of gold and epic
combat skills i happen to believe that
malice is also inspired by a substance
we see
in princess mononoke spoiler warning for
those who haven't seen the movie by the
way
near the end of the film the humans led
by lady aboshi
remove the head of the dear god turning
its body into a corrupted version of the
nightwalker
spilling sentient goop all over the land
that removes the life of anything it
comes in contact with
this corrupted dear god goop is what i
believe malice was inspired by as well
both are similarly goopy are sentient
and will destroy life
on contact they're also both of a
similar coloration
but there is one more similarity that
the substances share that we weren't
able to see
until the breath of the wild 2 trailer
and that is the fact that in either case
the goopy substance originates from an
individual
in the film the mononoke malice
originates from the deer god's body and
in breath of the wild
malice comes from ganondorf's corpse but
the reason why i'm taking so long to
cover their similarities is to point out
the fact that mononoke malice wasn't
created without something
happening to its point of origin the
deer god and i believe the same could be
true for ganondorf
the deer god stimulus was its head being
removed making the mononoke malice
spread
but ganondorf still has his head could
something else have happened to his body
that resulted in the creation of
malice well let me set something up real
quick before answering that in breath of
the wild
we can see the minions of ganon
everywhere but their quote-unquote
leader calamity gannon is a mindless
monster
who is incapable of speech how could
this amalgamation of weaponry
and goop have possibly intelligently
formulated armies and led forces against
hyrule
well let me tell you a story once upon a
time the legend of zelda was a new
franchise
35 years ago in fact the first zelda
game was so well received that nintendo
made a sequel and this sequel was called
zelda 2 and because it was a direct
sequel it had to take place after the
events of the original game
this was before the sloppy timeline
stuff anyway so story wise since link
defeated ganon at the end of the first
game
ganon was effectively dead in the second
game but yet his minions ran around the
world of hyrule trying to kill link just
the same
but why you ask their leader was dead so
they should have just you know
given up right well in the official game
manual we're given some insight into the
reasoning behind
ganon's monsters still roaming about you
see they wanted to kill link
so that they could then drain the blood
from his body and sprinkle it over the
ashes of the evil king
doing so according to this official
manual would revive
ganon now back to breath of the wild i'm
not trying to say for
certain which timeline the game takes
place in but many people already believe
it takes place at the end of the fallen
timeline matpat from game theory even
has a pretty compelling theory about
this placement as well
if this is the case then that places
breath of the wild
immediately after zelda 2 in the
timeline the last thing we knew about
gannon was that he was indeed dead but
his minions were trying to revive him
with the blood of the link that killed
him
the link from zelda 1. we can only
assume that the minions were trying to
accomplish what we saw them attempting
to do in zelda 2
and that is to find link and revive
ganon
and what we are left with in the game
breath of the wild
is a revived form of ganon created out
of malice
by the way have you ever wondered why
malice seems oddly familiar as a
substance
i mean it's this weird dark reddish
purplish
goop that we've never seen in a video
game before but it is very similar to a
certain real-life substance that
everyone is familiar with
blood malice has many similarities to
coagulated blood
such as its goopy sticky sometimes
stringy nature
and deeply red color calamity ganon's
resurrection cocoon in the royal chamber
of hyrule castle is even stylized to
resemble a hanging human heart
and has veins delivering malice to and
from the cocoon much like our blood
vessels deliver blood to and from our
hearts
the creations of pure malice the ganons
are all
oddly shaped because they have no actual
solid form they're just
globs of coagulated malice with shika
technology scattered throughout their
bodies
and they bleed out violently when
defeated the final piece to this blood
puzzle
would be the fact that malice has been
shown to originate from ganondorf's
corpse
giving even more credence to its
similarities to blood but the final
question remains
if malice is a form of corrupted blood
that's coming from ganondorf's corpse
why
is his blood so powerful and infinitely
limitless
well what if it's not just his blood but
the corrupted blood of link from zelda
2.
if you think about it the only way to
ensure that link's blood from zelda 2
wouldn't be used for the revival of
ganon would be to hide link's body away
after he dies of his eventual natural
death
given that link was able to even avoid
being killed and captured by ganon's
minions for his entire life in the first
place
however keeping something like that
hidden would be impossibly difficult
especially when you take into
consideration the limitless amount of
time that ganon's minions have
to roam about searching for the body so
what if they eventually were successful
and did in fact
pour link's blood onto the corpse of
ganondorf after the events of zelda 2
corrupting it with demise's malicious
hatred that resided within ganondorf and
turning it into
malice with the sole purpose of reviving
ganon
that would explain why even though
malice is an obviously supernatural
substance that spreads
infinitely and can even corrupt pools of
water in hyrule to spread further
it ultimately serves to form ganons over
and over again and at certain intervals
on certain nights ganon's malice surges
in power across the land of hyrule under
the light of a blood moon
so there you have it my crazy short
theory that malice could actually be the
tainted blood of the hero
now how does the green hand from the
trailer tie into all this
i'm not sure to be honest while it does
appear to be some sort of either living
or man-made construct that's attempting
to stop the outward flow of malice from
ganondorf's corpse it also seems to be
not only kind of failing at that job but
also
extracting the malice from the body as
nintendo black crisis discovered in a
video last year
some people speculate that it's the soul
of a previous link and with this theory
that could imply that it is the soul of
link from zelda to
trying to do something to prevent the
spread of malice but i digress
it's just too vague to figure out for
sure at this point once again this
theory is definitely a crazy one and not
really even one that i 100 subscribe to
but it's too interesting to ignore in my
opinion plus you guys
know i love doing videos like this that
just make people think about something
different than usual
that being said though what do you think
am i on to something here and malice was
created from the tainted blood of a
previous hero
or is that way off and malice is just
you know an unexplained goop thing now
let me know in the comments below thank
you guys so much for watching
i had a lot of fun making this theory
and hope you enjoyed the watch either
way
please consider dropping a like below to
get this video spread around on youtube
and clicking that subscribe button to
stick around for
more zelda and nintendo content to come
as always huge thanks to all of my
fantastic supporters of which i have
some amazing new faces to introduce
first and foremost i have a new super
supporter named bloody pirate
who joined the ranks of my elite at the
top
tier thank you so much i also have
rhiannon and joseph r
gabrielle autumn and the b ceredoka
who have all joined the ranks as well
thank you all
so very much you have more of an impact
on this channel than you'll ever know
if any of you watching are interested in
helping the next video come to life
feel free to check out that join button
located below each video or follow the
links in the description
to find out how on patreon also down in
that description
area are the links to my social media
pages so if you want to see the kinds of
nonsense i post like this right here
come on over and follow me on twitter
that's all i've got for this video so i
hope you have a
wonderful rest of your day this is mass
intended bandit signing out
[Music]
you